le château de versailles n'est pas le
seul monument à avoir fermé ses portes
c'est le cas aussi de celui de breteuil
située à choiseul une situation
difficile alors que l'an dernier le site
battait son record historique de
fréquentation avec plus de 125 mille
visiteurs c'est également la première
fois depuis 1969 que son propriétaire le
marquis henri-françois de breteil
redécouvre le site totalement vide pour
la période de pâques
lui qui apprécie ouvrir les jardins pour
les chasses aux oeufs des enfants
écouter le château a perdu
provisoirement la vie qu'on lui avait
donné depuis 50 ans l'impression qu'on
est sous louis xiv ou moi je vais jalava
ce que je vis tout le temps ici mais mes
enfants etc sont arrivés la nuit qui
suivit la fermeture nous avons trois
personnes qui continuent à travailler
ici sur les dix qui sont plutôt des
personnes qui sont des entretiens et des
travaux et parce que ça il y en a
toujours
en revanche les personnes qui étaient là
pour l'animation pour le paysage visiter
ces terrains sont en chômage partiel
puisqu'il n'y a plus de travail pour eux
malheureusement et notre effort bien sûr
c'est que l'on puisse rev'it rouvrir les
portes du château